[Música]
salud en directo américa en france 24
más romero sala ya está conmigo en el
estudio mar felicidades para ti
comenzamos con una noticia muy relevante
desde eeuu el ente regulador de ese país
la sda aprobó no la combinación de las
vacunas y también las dosis de refuerzo
contra el coach 19 así es raúl y es de
mucha importancia porque de hecho este
ente regulador la fd a no por sus siglas
en inglés está marcando los pasos un
poco de la lucha contra la pandemia
repasemos cuáles son las decisiones que
han tomado porque puede ser un poco
enredado
antes que nada aprobaron la
definitivamente las terceras dosis las
dosis de refuerzo más que todo de las
vacunas que se están aplicando en el
país de johnson y johnson de modernas y
the fighter pero moderna y facer sólo
para personas en riesgo es decir mayores
de 65 años o personas con condiciones
previas de salud mientras que la de
johnson johnson para la población
general para mí esa es una de las
noticias más importantes de las que
estamos hablando hoy porque le han
recomendado para todo el mundo y la han
recomendado dos meses después de la
primera aplicación eso hace despertar
ciertas preguntas de por qué no se
considera johnson y johnson como una
vacuna de 2 desde desde el inicio pero
bueno esto tocará ver en el futuro cómo
se va desarrollando y finalmente qué
decisiones toman el otro gran titular es
el que llaman mix en mano la combinación
de vacunas distintas para inmunizarse
contra el commit 19 no hay una
recomendación específica de la fd al
respecto no están lo dejan un poco como
al libre albedrío de las personas de
elegir qué dosis de refuerzo se quieren
aplicar pero precisamente ayer estábamos
hablando de esto en nuestra sección de
salud y hay estudios que muestran que
combinar vacunas de distintos tipos es
decir de arene mensajero como pueden ser
fans de vida moderna y de vectoriales de
virus inactivados como puede ser si
novak o johnson y johnson precisamente
dan más inmunidad que combinar hay que
poner vacunas del mismo fármaco y nos lo
explicaba precisamente el médico ayer
escuchemos lo que nos contaba roberto de
bach
tienen diferentes mecanismos de
presentación de lo que se llama el
antígeno lo que a la inmunidad y la
inmunidad responde de diferente manera
esta es la base racional por la cual
aparece en estas fechas de vacunación es
heteróloga combinadas el factor de qué
tiene procesos diferentes y de inmunidad
responde doblemente porque lo que se
está viendo es que cuando se combinan
vacunas vuelvo a decir aumentan varias
veces la inmunidad en relación con si
hubiera utilizado el mismo fármaco muy
importante esta respuesta inmune pero no
sólo eso sino también las consecuencias
logísticas que puede tener para países
con poco acceso precisamente a las
vacunas la posibilidad de combinar en
américa latina' tendremos que estar
pendientes de que también se apruebe en
los países de la región para facilitar y
para acelerar las campañas de vacunación
así es marc y seguimos con kobe 19
porque tenemos nuevos datos sobre la
respuesta inmune de las personas que ya
han sido contagiadas del virus como
usted y yo exacto básicamente es que no
tenemos tanta prisa para conseguir una
dosis de refuerzo como una persona que
nos ha contagiado esta es la principal
conclusión de un estudio de la revista
neichel que se publicó ayer y que
estudiaba la respuesta inmunológica de
las personas que ya se han contagiado de
kobe ty que luego se vacunaron es lo que
se llama inmunidad híbrida y básicamente
la principal conclusión es que la
respuesta inmune de estas personas es
superior a las personas que no se
conocieron de kobe pero que si están
vacunadas algunos de los gráficos veamos
que publicaron en el estudio
básicamente miran en azul se ven la
respuesta inmune de las personas que no
han sido vacuna hay perdón que no se han
contagiado de covite ción de las que
llamamos seronegativas en rojo vemos la
seropositivas las que se así se han
contagiado de covite y luego se han
vacunado lo que nos importa aquí es ver
como la densidad de esos puntos es la
respuesta inmune es lo que está midiendo
y vemos que en ambos casos tanto contra
la variante original de kobe 19 como
contra la variante delta la respuesta
siempre es más robusta en el caso de las
personas que primero se han contagiado y
que luego se vacunaron esto es muy
importante porque bueno básicamente nos
dice que aunque nos hayamos contagiado
como tú y como yo también tenemos que
vacunarnos maris o bien la tarea
estudiándose ese gráfico que tanto lo
hizo ayer pero ahora vamos a terminar
hablando de la vacunación pero no contra
el commit 19 sino contra otra enfermedad
la fiebre amarilla en venezuela te toca
estudiar mucho para hablar de estas
cosas conclusión de has todo esto lo
estamos hablando de la venezuela porque
hay una reciente alerta de la
organización panamericana de la salud
por fiebre amarilla en el país
latinoamericano son 7 personas que se
han contagiado ya de las cuales 6 no
estaban vacunadas no es el primer brote
que sucede en los últimos años de una
enfermedad que se consideraba que estaba
ya bajo control y que ha vuelto a
reaparecer escuchemos lo que nos dicen
los profesionales desde el país
si sabíamos que había una disminución de
coberturas de vacunación que
puntualmente para la vacuna toxoide
tetánico diftérico y el sarampión
rubéola y parotiditis habían aumentado
después del surgimiento de la
reemergencia de sarampión para el año
2017 y de difteria que fue en el año
2016 que hay inmunoprevenibles surgen re
emergen cuando bajan las coberturas de
vacunación cuando la gente se deja de
vacunar y es lo que ha ocurrido
lamentablemente durante los últimos años
en venezuela y esto se ha profundizado
durante la pandemia de la cob y 19 muy
importante recordar que no solo las
vacunas contra el coventry cionales son
las que nos importan no estamos hablando
de difteria de malaria de sarampión
brotes de enfermedades que se
consideraban desaparecidos desde finales
del siglo 20 en venezuela y que en los
últimos cinco años han vuelto a
reaparecer algo que pone de manifiesto
la fragilidad del sistema de salud en el
país también la falta de vigilancia
epidemiológica la falta de control
y también de cobertura de la vacunación
raúl no debemos dejar de lado este tipo
de enfermedades que no son cobit pero
que también nos afectan y no suelen
venezuela también hay que ir al médico y
recurrentemente y pues estar pendientes
de otras enfermedades que pueden
presentarse en nuestros cuerpos
marc muchísimas gracias por toda la
información mañana nos vemos con más
salud